the aim is of course to ensure that we
can continue and also strengthen our
support to Ukraine because we have seen
that Russia has
suffered uh uh big losses in in Ukraine
due to the brave uh Ukrainian soldiers
and and the professionalism and
education of the Ukrainian Armed Forces
but we should not underestimate Russia
they are mobilizing more troops they are
working hard to acquire more equipment
more ammunition and they are shown a
willingness to actually suffer but
continue the war and there is no
indication that President Putin has
changed the overall aim of his uh brutal
war against Ukraine so we need to be
prepared for the Long Haul the European
Union will keep doing everything in its
power to support the brave people of
Ukraine we will keep the pressure on the
Kremlin for as long as it takes with the
biting sanctions regime
we will extend these sanctions to those
who militarily support Russia's War such
as Belarus
or Iran
and we will be coming forward with new
sanctions on Belarus answering their
Belarus roles role in this Russian war
in Ukraine I have said many times since
the beginning of Russia's invasion in
Ukraine that I think that Ukraine should
God get all the necessary military
equipment they need and they can handle
to defend their Homeland and this means
of course Advanced Air Defense systems
but also other types of advanced
military equipment as long as it is
necessary to defend Ukraine because they
also defend the basic principles of the
U.N Charter of the fundamental rights
and of the international law and I
welcome the new announcements uh just
the last days by the United States
Germany France to also provide new types
of
um of armored vehicles a infantry
fighting vehicles and other types of
armor to to Ukraine I welcome the focus
on systems but I think we need to also
realize that this is not only about
adding more systems more platforms more
weapons but also ensuring that the
platforms the weapons we have already
provided are working as they should we
are determined to take the partnership
between NATO and the European Union to
the next level
to address in particular the growing
geostrategic competition resilience
issues and the protection of critical
infrastructures as well as emerging and
disruptive Technologies space the
security implications of climate change
for interference and information
manipulation